so you're not going to understand why
I'm uh telling you about this story but
I'll explain it will explain
so bear with me uh this from Fox News
the Atlanta Falcons made a hard turn
with their coaching search the Falcons
despite interviewing bill belchic twice
hired Los Angeles Rams defensive
coordinator Raheem Morris to fill their
head coaching
vacancy fa the Falcons made the deal
official later on
Thursday Arthur Blank the owner said
this is a historic day for the Atlanta
Falcons uh we're thrilled to welcome
rahee Morris back to Atlanta blah blah
blah
okay so you may be wondering why I'm
wasting your time with NFL coaching news
aside from the fact that I'm we are
going to the conference championships
the Ravens are my team on Sunday I'm
pretty excited about it cannot share my
excitement with anybody outside of my
own household because nobody here cares
about football this is this is a Titans
Town none of you people care you know so
I have nobody I can talk to about it
with so and anyway don't feel well you
should feel a little sorry for me about
that but that's not the only reason um
there's another reason too and because
this coaching news presents some some
fascinating problems for the left's
narrative and it kind of shows you how
the left's narrative works and here's
why Raheem Morris who just got the head
coach gig Atlanta he's been around the
league for a while he's a relatively
young guy he's like 47 48 years old but
he's been around the league for a long
for a while and he got his first head
coach job like 15 years
ago um he has a track record and it's
not good he he has a losing record as a
head coach thoroughly a thoroughly
losing record so it's not even close to
500 it's it's he's probably 300 or
something um he's never been to a Super
Bowl he has I don't think he has any
playoff wins um he has nothing you know
it's just he has failed in his uh in his
head coaching opportunities in the past
uh he has been poor To Mediocre mediocre
has been kind of his ceiling when really
he's been a poor head coach and he's
also he's also a black man meanwhile
there is another head coach free agent
on the market as referenced in the
article named Bill bellich who you've
probably heard of uh he has six Super
Bowl rings um he has more wins than any
other coach in the history of the game
except for one and he's he's he's you
know he's with he's within Striking
Distance of having the most wins out of
any coach who's ever uh coached in in
professional football he interviewed for
this job twice which is I don't know if
I can quite explain
how uh what that means like he he took
two interviews this guy's a shoe in for
the Hall of Fame and he took two
interviews he he not only interviewed
once like you would
think right if I was Bill bellich I
wouldn't I wouldn't take any interview
in the first place I would say I gotta
interview for the job Bill bich what do
you mean I gotta interview for the job
like you know what I can do I'm not
going to interview with you much less
come back a second time that's like it's
like if Daniel D
Lewis not only came into audition for
your role in your movie but actually
came in for a follow-up aition audition
and he was auditioning against just like
guys who have acted in commercials and
then he doesn't get the gig like it's
like that Grant can University is an
affordable private Christian University
based in Phoenix Arizona they're
dedicated to making education fit into
your already busy schedule which is why
they offer 270 of their academic
programs online for from scholarship to
academic support gcu's graduation team
provides you with the personal support
you need to obtain your goals gcu's
online program offers you the freedom to
earn your degree on your own time from
wherever you are GCU is praise for its
culture of community giving an impact
the integrate the free market system and
a welcoming Christian worldview into all
of their academic programs achieve your
goals with a personalized plan and a
supportive team behind you find your
purpose at Grand Canyon University
private Christian affordable visit
gcu.edu that's GC u.edu I'm not saying
that Rahim Morris got the job because
he's black I'm not saying this is a
diversity Dei hire situation I I mean
I'm I'm legitimately not saying that
okay not being koyi when I say it's like
I I don't think that's what happened the
NFL uh now they do have a ridiculous
policy the Rooney Rule where you where
you teams have to interview minority
candidates for head coaching gigs even
if they already know who they want they
have to go they have to go through the
motions of um interviewing minority
but I don't think he got the job because
he's black I think he got it because one
of the quirks of the NFL is that you
know you've got These Guys these kind of
um mediocre coaches who who've never
accomplished anything who just sort of
hang around for decades and they keep
getting jobs and this is black and white
coaches this happens with uh mediocrity
in in the NFL is colorblind you've just
got it's it no one quite it's
frustrating and and confounding for the
fans no one quite understand you just
got these guys it's like Jeff fiser
coach of the Titans uh for many years is
one of these guys he just mediocre all
he ever did was he he'd go 500 in the
season he kept getting jobs and no one
could figure out why all I'm saying is
that the sports media and the left have
claimed and still claim that the NFL is
racist against black
coaches uh which which is absurd on its
face for a million reasons we talked
about before but if you actually
believed that it was
true well this event should should shake
your faith in that theory to its core
because if the NFL is racist against
black coaches how in God's name could a
black coach with a losing record and no
rings get a job over a white coaching
Legend with six rings who interviewed
for the job
twice uh it's it's like
impossible right if you didn't know
anything about the NFL and someone told
you uh the first thing they told you is
look first thing you need to know about
this league is they're racist against
black coaches that's the that's you need
to know that okay you you would not
predict based on that theory that there
could ever be a scenario where a losing
black coach could get a job over a white
Coach who's been to the Super Bowl and
won it six
times um because it just doesn't make
any sense but will
this event um uh cause the the the and
by the way it's not like Raheem Morris
is the first black coach with a losing
record to get a job as I said happens
many times in this case it's just it's
even
more uh noticeable given who he got the
job
over but will this cause the race
Hustlers the Jamal Hills of the world to
reconsider or recalibrate will they look
at this and say hm okay well you know
that's that's not quite what we would
expect if given that the NFL is races
against head coaches we thought thought
blackhead coaches okay like I'm not even
saying will they
abandon their theory of systemic racism
against black coaches in the NFL and in
society generally of course they're not
going to abandon it but will they even
like take it into account uh will will
it be a data point that they look at and
and and try to factor into their
equation well no of course not
because uh this is why I say systemic
racism in every aspect of life including
in the NFL
is an
unfalsifiable Theory there there is
nothing that can happen that will ever
cause the people who believe in this
Theory and who who have postulated this
Theory there is nothing that can ever
happen that will ever disprove or
discredit or or even weaken this theory
in their minds
unfalsifiable which is why it is an
illegitimate and false theory in the end
if you like to see what else I have to
say you can access my full show by going
to dailywire.com or by going to the Matt
wall Show Twitter page hope to see you
there godp speed